morgan what's going on hi dr dolani
thank you so much for having me
thank you for calling how in the world
are you good how are you
good good good all right so what's up
how can i help
okay so we just became a first time
foster family
a few months ago to a newborn baby yeah
dude congratulations
thank you what a hate um that's a long
arduous road
you are hard a hero without a cave it is
super hard
do you have your own kids i do how many
you got
i have a i have a seven-year-old or a
yeah seven-year-old boy and a
nine-year-old girl
oh my you are changing
legacy oh thank you listen
i know you feel like uh things that all
the trains have derailed
everywhere but listen what you are doing
for those two kids
your biological kids what are you doing
for that
foster kid what you're doing for your
marriage is
messy and bananas and extraordinary
thank you thank you thank you thank you
all right so what's your question thank
you
so my question is this is our first
foster baby we want to do foster care
for a long time
um i am terrified to say goodbye to this
little one
and the main goal of foster care is
reunification which i think is great
um that sounds super good until you hold
that baby right
it is it's so hard and i i just think
about
not seeing him again and i don't know
how i'm gonna do it and how my kids
like how i'm gonna help my kids through
that so i'm wondering if you have any
advice for
any tools yes so i
actually um i've got several close
friends who have
i've just been able to watch navigate
this for 10 15 years some of them and so
um yeah there's some tough lessons
learned and some beautiful things that
have
come from this it's hard to see when
you're in the middle of this
banana season right um you
said the most important thing that's
hard to get people to turn to
which is what is my number one job
and it's to hold and love
and model the love for this baby knowing
that the single most important person in
his life is not me
and that is so hard to do right
right and i know that mentally yeah yes
i'm trying to get there emotionally
so i want you to be really graceful with
yourself
especially with with baby number one
baby number two baby number three this
is so so hard
so let me ask you a few questions about
this do you have any connection to
babies mom or dad are you a part of
helping them with services
can you be i
can be um
the only reason i'm not is
i have two little ones of my own and
i have no judgment towards family
whatsoever
but i get a little nervous bringing
people into our lives that i don't know
sure so if that makes sense
yes and you've brought a baby into your
life
and so you've brought an entire family
system into your life
and so you can't um you can't bring this
baby in
you can't take the good parts without
the scary parts
that's true good parts of this little
baby the scary part so there's there an
entire family system that if it were
working perfectly
this kid would not be in this situation
right so
one or two of my friends who have done
this beautifully
have actually taken the
hearts and minds of the family this
baby's moving back into
into consideration so they have offered
things like
parenting like parenting coaching for
the mom or the or the dad
regular coffee visits how are you doing
and here's what happens over time most
not always
but most of the time parents will take
you up on that because they're desperate
and they will see something that you
have that they don't which is peace
right peace in the only chaotic
peace that a mother of a nine and a
seven seven-year-old have right
which is not day-to-day peace not sleep
not hair looks good or my makeup is all
crazy
but that piece that knows this is right
you know what i mean
and so offering hey i'll meet with you
once every two weeks i'm gonna get a
babysitter for my kids or while they're
in school we're gonna go meet for coffee
somewhere
and if you don't feel comfortable yet in
your home that's great that's no problem
but it will give you a sense of empathy
for them too because they've got a story
to tell as well
so i'm going to tell you about a
conversation i had in grad school that
was a healing moment for me
it was a moment of shame for me and then
a moment of healing so
i was working as in a placement with an
extraordinary psychologist who just
worked with traumatized kids
and we had just left another situation
where a mom
was not working her services and in my
head
had chosen drugs over her kid that's how
i had framed
this thing and i was so angry and i was
running my mouth and he gently turned to
me and said and i said something along
the lines some
patriot like patronizing man i can't
believe that
whatever mom chose whatever instead of
that beautiful little kid
and the psychologist just said to me man
if you knew mom's story
meth makes a lot of sense her life has
been
hell and just that one sentence of
man if you knew her story you have no
idea
right and it instantly made me feel
ridiculous for running my mouth
about a mother who i didn't know
comparing her situation to mine i had a
newborn and i thought i was all high and
mighty
but what it really did was it set me on
a rabbit hole
in of empathy how can i hear other
people's stories and hear what's going
on in their hearts and minds and how can
i be a part of that narrative not the
blaming and shaming and screaming and
yelling at people narrative
and so listen once i started hearing
these stories
oh my gosh seven drinks makes a lot of
sense man
you know what i mean and it helped me
navigate a whole new it helped open my
eyes to a whole new thing so i'm telling
you
you your first thoughts are i'm not
judging but
we're all we've all been there okay i
think it would do your
soul a world of good to offer and they
may not take you up on it and you'll get
frustrated by it
and but you're gonna get to see another
side of a human being's story and you
may get to pass along some great skills
and here's
all of this is headed towards this a lot
of these families are still in
connection with my friends
the kids are still in connection their
parents are so
grateful for the human connection
because they have court they have the
mandated counseling
they've got the aaa meetings you have to
attend they don't have any relationships
and that are outside of the family or
drugs or whatever and
whoa what a gift you can be morgan okay
so here's here's another thing
um and my friend slade has has taught me
this
and i have never done it so i'm just
talking to you third hand okay
he says they own the collective grief
every time as a family
they take the kid back it just hurts
and it stinks and there is something so
beautiful and legacy changing about
teaching your children
modeling for your children that
relationship is risk and relation
relationships include
pain and it hurts
and it's worth it
right that's a really good way to look
at it and so
what i didn't know until i was married
for 10 years was that relationships suck
and they're really hard
when i started thinking of exit
strategies right
and you will have given your kids an
understanding of no no relationships are
really hard and they're good and they're
worth it and they're so awful and you
cry
and and and they're still right
and you will get to honor your kids that
and there is no magic sauce for that
there's just lots and lots and lots of
hugs
uh slade who's like a super in shape
like he was my workout partner for years
he talked about they dropped off one of
their kids
and they just made their way to a taco
bell which is not a food him and his
family would normally eat
and he said they were they were just
silent and then the person in front of
them just mysteriously paid for their
mini van full of
people and he said there was some moment
of grace there they all cried they all
laughed and there was just this
collection collective
this sucks but we're gonna be okay and
let's go help somebody else does that
make sense
yeah so i guess i i need to get past my
i'm very like positive everything's okay
everything's good we'll be fine
no and maybe you need to get more into
the heaviness of it
that it's gonna suck well and you will
be fine
right and you'll be fine yeah and
relationship is worth the pain
right and it just because it hurts
doesn't mean it's wrong
and our kids are growing up in a world
where discomfort has been
pathologized right discomfort has been
made the bad guy and it's not
right discomfort's just a signal that we
really loved hard and it hurts
what a magical gift you will give to
them and
bring them along for this ride let them
know hey
it's you they're foster baby too they
get to help with breakfast and diapers
and reading stories oh my gosh
you are giving them a magical laboratory
for love
are they oh thank you they're awesome
helpers yep they love this little baby
and
it's been great awesome so listen don't
ever
let them catch you talking bad about the
other family
no i never do don't ever let them catch
you
trying to hide emotions just be just
live and love recklessly in front of
them
and let them absorb all of you all of
this baby
and man what a gift you're giving them
what a gift you are giving them giving
them there is no way to make this not
hard
it's just hard right
you've given me a great perspective of
where to go with it
well and i really really want you to
think about channeling
into a conversation or a meeting a
regular connection with
um this baby's mom and or this baby's
dad
if if it's safe and the courts will
allow it i would love to see you reach
out and do that
it's going to be clarifying for you and
along the way
if you really believe reunification is
the best and that's where you got to be
it's where you got to be and i know you
look at your house and you think nobody
could love this baby like i do
you also have your two kids and you know
that nobody can love your two kids like
you can
right right and so that little baby's
got a mom and a daddy out there
somewhere
right and they're loving sideways and
crooked and they are
broken and stumbling but that right
place for that kid
unless there is pain and hurt is with
their mom and dad
and so man you can teach them hey they
really love this
this baby loves this and laughs when you
do this and loves happiness
you could be such a bridge to that
family and a
gift that will be legacy i mean family
tree changing for
your family and theirs and for everybody
listening
foster parents are absolute rock star
heroes it
is the hardest thing
whether you're fostering to adopt or
you're just doing foster appearing you
are opening up your heart
with full understanding that there is
hurt on the other end for you
best case scenario the kid leaves and it
hurts
worst case scenario parents aren't able
to complete their services or choose not
to complete their services or whatever
the baby has to move on to a foster home
you're hurt
but in the middle you get to
model for a baby that they have value
they're worth being loved you get to
model for a middle schooler that's
never had somebody look them in the eye
and say you have worth
you get to take little snapshots in
history and plant
seeds in kids hearts oh my gosh and it
is hard hard hard and it is holy holy
good
great work if you've ever thought about
fostering please consider doing that
please consider doing that